so my friend barry weiss did a really
really interesting interview with kim
kardashian uh and and you know
i know i know we're gonna talk about kim
kardashian but it's a thing so here's
the thing kim kardashian is an insanely
famous human being the number of social
media followers she has is just beyond
crazy we were talking about hundreds of
millions of people who follow her on
various social media outlets
and she's been involved in politics in
some kind of interesting and weird ways
obviously kim kardashian worked with the
trump administration to do criminal
justice reform now i have very serious
problems with the actual policy of
criminal justice reform like real
problems with it i think that that
criminal justice reform is rooted in the
notion that we have this this prison
pipeline and the entire interest of the
american system is in keeping people in
prison who are innocent and ought to be
out on the streets there may be isolated
cases where people ought to be released
because they've been rehabilitated but
the vast majority of people who are in
prison are in prison for a pretty damned
good reason and releasing them back out
onto the streets is only going to result
in higher levels of crime because
recidivism rates are very very high
so i'm not a big fan of criminal justice
reform but kim kardashian actually has
some interesting things to say about how
to work across the aisle and they're
much more i would say well spoken and
effective in how most people think in
terms of american politics these days so
barry weiss
asked kim kardashian about the criticism
she received for working with trump and
for normalizing him and here's some of
kim k i i really don't care about the
criticism i mean
my reputation over someone's life like
destroyed me then i don't i really don't
care like it was not even an an option
and he did the right thing so i'm
i'm just about
doing the right thing and
i'm really not about politics at all
like it's really about the people inside
and if i can do anything no matter if
it's
obama biden trump like i'm really
willing to work with anybody and i think
that i also give credit where credit's
due he did a lot for justice reform and
um
you know i kind of
stay focused on what i need to get done
and i think i've been really vocal about
not
making it about politics for me
and it's not really about being liked
what would that change if i could change
someone's life
you know that's that's what it's about
for me and so barry weiss followed up on
that by saying well you know you've been
sort of hit by cancel culture right
cancel culture has come after you for a
variety of reasons and again kim
kardashian sounds kind of like a sane
and rational human being
now because you know there was one time
where people attacked her because she
had named her company kimono they said
it was cultural appropriation
and she said well i guess i'll change
that but then there's there have been
other times where people accuse her of
that and she's like nah here's what she
had to say i
always want to take everything seriously
if it comes to something as serious as
cultural appropriating even if i know my
intentions i never want to take anything
lightly
and
in the instance of kimono and changing
that name
it was an innocent name that you know
the the team came up with
and
people were very
loud about that and felt a serious way
about it and when i got a letter from
the japanese officials i took it
extremely seriously it wasn't even a
question i was like i absolutely would
never want to
make anyone feel like i was
appropriating their culture
and i
got this serious letter and i will make
a serious change and i immediately just
halted production and there was a lot of
pieces in production
and i said give me a week and i had to
think of a new name and anyone that is
starting a business knows
how difficult it is to come up with a
name and trademarking and everything and
i took it really seriously and it just
wasn't even an option
but here's where it gets interesting
still if i worried about every last
thing someone said and i had to try to
change it i would never be me anyone
wouldn't be them that's why i think
cancel culture is the most ridiculous
thing because i really do believe and
you and i have been at several dinners
together where people are discussing
their thoughts on it in rehabilitation
and freedom of speech i've never really
been in to cancel culture
she says i believe if we cancel someone
for something they had done or said in
their past we're not inviting them into
the conversation to really understand it
depends on the situation and this is kim
kardashian who is sounding a lot more
sane than people on the radical left who
i'm sure she's surrounded by constantly
again kim kardashian saying an
intelligent thing you know you might not
care if it's absolutely ridiculous
but i mean it's it's a fine line
honestly of like like you were asking in
the original question of when do you let
something go yes and when do you you
know have your thick skin and not care
what people say about you which is
the more that i don't care about fame
the less i care to correct people
i i don't really care what people think
about me but there's sometimes where i
say okay i completely understand how you
would feel like this is disrespectful
and i will absolutely change this i
always own up to the mistakes that i
make i try to not make them again
and that's just how i live my life but i
think to not have these conversations
with people
how are they ever going to change if
there's something that isn't
right that's being said if you just shut
them out it'll make them more angry
we'll get to more on kim kardashian's
rather shockingly interesting interview
in just one moment first this holiday
season deck the halls walls windows and
doors of the best deals of the year on
the award-winning ring alarm i'm sure we
all know about that ring video doorbell
by now but did you know that ring makes
an award-winning alarm ring alarm is a
powerful affordable whole home security
system you can easily install yourself
so whether you're busy running across
town or across the country you and your
loved ones can rest easy knowing your
home is protected it's more than just
security ring alarm protects your home
from flood freeze and fire as well it's
a lot cheaper than those other companies
for what they charge for one month and
get an entire year of ring alarm with
professional monitoring right now the
best deals of the year on ring alarm go
to ring.com forward slash man i'm
constantly using my ring app like i'm
sure that as soon as we finish doing
this show today i'm going to be checking
my ring app to see what my baby is doing
in the backyard it is inevitably
something hilarious so this holiday
season deck the halls walls windows and
doors the best deals of the year on the
award-winning ring alarm go to ring.com
forward slash man get a great deal on
that ring alarm security kit today that
is ring.com forward slash ben again
ring.com forward slash ben protect
yourself smartwayring.com forward slash
ben and then she responded to barry
weiss's comments about kanye west so she
asked about kanye wearing a maga hat on
snl right there's a very famous moment
in sort of american cultural history one
of the oddities of the last several
years here's kim k talking to barry
weiss i was very
nervous
i didn't want him to wear the red hat
on snl i'm not really a rule breaker so
my personality would be like okay you
guys don't like the red hat i'll take it
off
and i remember
other people were around and it became a
thing where he wasn't going to go on
because he wanted to be who he is
and i'm very neutral but i was very that
night i was very forceful with him and
arguing with him about you know you have
to take that hat off
and now looking back i thought why
should he take that off if that's what
he believes in
why can't he wear that on tv half of the
country voted for him
so clearly other people like him also i
just i'm
i learned a lot
from that situation and
no matter what it taught me to be a
little bit more empathetic for people
that just
want to do what they want to do and like
freedom of speech and if you want to
wear the hat wear the hat like i respect
the fact that he knew exactly what he
believed in and always stood by that
and that to me is like
a good quality to have
no matter
who is against you and no matter what
the circumstances are i think that it's
just like admirable and that's just like
a really cool quality i think even if
it's not what i agree with or even if i
would have done it differently i think
it's commendable so honestly good for
her
seriously good for her
and kim kardashian sounds a hell of a
lot more grounded than
half the people that you see
on the on the left
like that that is a that is a
that is a positive
and
we need more celebrities who are willing
to do this sort of stuff it is amazing
by the way how many celebrities you'll
talk to people who are overtly
conservative
and they are so afraid of the blowback
but this is the thing if we have more
celebrities who just say listen come
after me do what you will but i'm just
gonna still be here when this is all
over
this would be over all it takes is some
people standing up and saying no
kim kardashian actually did she stood up
and she said i have a priority i don't
agree with her priority but she says i'm
gonna work with trump to do it and if
you don't like it stuff it
and now she's saying that she didn't
even take that far enough with kanye
kanye wearing a maga hat on snl it's
like well if he wants to wear a magic
hat he should wear a mega hat you know
what happened nothing kanye is still
extraordinarily famous his albums still
sell bajillion bajillion copies kim
kardashian is still extraordinarily
famous
the the key is you have to have people
who in fact are willing to do something
that
i can't believe i'm saying this that kim
k will do
which is that she will tell people to to
screw off she'll say she'll say listen
if it's a legit criticism i'll take it
under advisement but if it's not legit
forget it
good for her she sounds like actually a
fairly well-grounded human being now i'm
not gonna make any comment about her
dating of uh pete davidson i wanted to
kill myself when i was eight um i think
that your decision making politically
and your decision making
in your personal life apparently are two
completely separate
things
because yeah man that's that that there
are some decisions that are better than
others
they didn't get into the pete davidson
dating in this particular interview
yeah
herald and maude
folks
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed